many countries around the world battle
second even third waves
of the coronavirus life in taiwan
appears near normal
the reason is success with battling the
pandemic
the numbers tell the tale a little more
than a thousand registered cases and
only 11 covet related deaths
for a population of nearly 24 million
strict quarantine controls and test and
trace are being attributed to the
island's remarkable success
in keeping case numbers low something
that was visible when a small
outbreak hit a large hospital back in
january
located near the airport taurian
hospital was one of taiwan's gatekeepers
against the virus
authorities had stand a fifth of
confirmed cases
here for treatment since the start of
2020
but in january this year an infected
doctor triggered the fresh outbreak
several of his co-workers were later
tested positive
taiwan faced its biggest coronavirus
crisis
since the start of the pandemic your
neck are not jesus
hospital acquired infection is very
serious and hard to control
patients in the hospital need health
care workers to take care of them
they're next to each other it's
impossible to just quarantine hospital
workers and leave patients alone
wong works at the central epidemic
command center
he soon decided to set himself up in the
hospital to directly oversee
communications from the command center
we had to contain the virus
in a large hospital of more than 2 600
employees
and around 700 impatiens one wrong
decision could lead to the tragedy
similar to the 2003 sars outbreak
then the government locked down a
hospital where even healthy people were
not allowed to leave
leading to 154 infections
and 31 deaths it was okay when there
were only one or two cases in the
hospital
but when there were more and more people
confirmed positive we were definitely
nervous
we were afraid of getting phone calls in
the middle of the night hearing about
yet another new case
this time the command center reacted
quickly
tracking all possible contacts and home
quarantining over 4
300 people they also transferred
negative tested patients to other
hospitals
to decrease the workload on staff after
14 days with no
new confirmed cases all hospital
employees had to do math testing to
convince the public
that the hospital is safe in 44 days the
outbreak was contained
with only 21 cases and just one death
transparency and honesty is the very
important
and you have to give the people the
reason why you want to have
a very stringent concentration and very
stringent home quarantine
and this and the evidence we have to
show the evidence that
it is very very useful to prevent the
future pandemic
chance that no countries can fight alone
i
would like to re-emphasize the important
thing is the prudence surveillance
we have to keep eye on the possible
outbreak in all
the countries to prevent its spread out
now taurian hospital is back to relative
normality
the stars experience reminded the
government and its people
not to let history repeat itself a
lesson not only for taiwan
but for the world in its approach to
tackling this fast-bred environment
jay patel is a researcher on global
covet 19 strategy
at the university of edinburgh and joins
me now from leeds in the uk
jay welcome now you study global
responses
to the coronavirus pandemic in your
assessment
what has taiwan done well
hi well taiwan focused uh very early on
on having an elimination strategy
they were not keen on this idea of
having community transmission where
we've got the virus circulating in a
population
so had a very early very rapid um and
focused effort
to eliminate any cases and clusters that
were emerging
from the initial china connection
and how were they able to implement this
so effectively
did they have any previous experience
with tackling pandemics that came in
handy
well the sars pandemic of 2003
certainly came in handy they had the
planning they had the pre-covered
infrastructure
to deal with pandemics well but above
all they
recognized that acting quickly and
trying to protect public health first of
all in an attempt to
recover economies after the pandemic
were crucial
and certainly applied those lessons to
covet 19 very well
it would appear that what you're saying
is it's quite
it makes a lot of sense to put it simply
i'm just wondering
why other countries could not draw this
same lesson
early on in the pandemic
uh well it's a difficult question to
answer but
perhaps one of the reasons is adopting
an influenza approach of a flu approach
which
many western countries had rather than a
sars plan
i suppose the primary difference between
the two is that flu
favors some level of endemicity i.e some
some circulation in the population to
build immunity
now the problem is that sars coronavirus
2 is much more
lethal it's much more transmissible and
so
that approach just simply would not work
it is also down to the fact that earlier
on in the pandemic
it wasn't really well known how
infectious the new coronavirus
the new coronal virus is
possibly yes um but in
in respect that actually enforces the
need to drive down cases to
as low as possible as quickly as
possible
when there are so many unknowns
exercising what's called the
precautionary principle
certainly has a lot of value and in the
western countries we didn't really see
that approach instead what we saw was a
a firm adherence to the existing flu
plans which were clearly not compatible
with this virus
right we leave it there for the time
being but thank you so much for
joining us jay patel from the university
of edinburgh